-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor,
writer, and musician.
He's currently starring
in "What Happens Later,"
which is in theaters
November 3rd.
Let's take a look.
-Still a music snob.
Oh, geez.
Remember,
you used to hide my CDs
when our friends came over?
Hey, when our friends came over,
you used to hide my CDs.
-One CD, one time,
the "Partridge Family
Christmas" album.
And I did that
to spare you the humiliation.
-So my taste of music
was humiliating.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, yeah? To who?
-To you.
-No, not to me.
To you.
-To me.
And to you.
-Sheesh.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend David Duchovny,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Take a seat.
-Thank you.
-It's lovely to have you here.
-It's nice to be back, Seth.
-You get to be in
a romantic comedy with Meg Ryan.
-I know.
-She directed it as well.
-I know. I know these things.
-Shot it.
You shot it?
Yeah. These are not --
I'm not telling you
anything you don't know.
-Really I did?
Whew.
-Good time to be
David Duchovny.
You shot most of it
in an airport.
-Yeah. Now it gets worse...
-Wow.
-As you go on.
-Meg --
Meg did not do herself
any favors
because it's not easy
to shoot a movie in an airport.
-No, because, well,
it was a regional airport,
so it did shut down
at like 9:00,
which is when we did
most of our shooting.
But we also had to shoot
sometimes during the day,
and there are just
people going
to and from
wherever they're going.
-So it's a working airport.
-It's a working airport.
-It's not an abandoned airport.
-And I don't know
if you know this,
but it's illegal to tell anybody
to do anything in an airport.
I've never tried to do it
before, but like, you can't say,
Seth, can you just sit there
for a moment
while David and Meg
shoot this scene
and you're like, no,
I've got to get to my gate.
-Interesting.
-Can't do it.
-So there's no --
There's no crowd control.
-Zero.
-And if I want to come over
and be like,
I'm a big fan of both of you
while you're filming.
-That's familiar
because that happened.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we would do these --
It's -- there's like long
walk-and talk scenes
in this movie like eight pages,
and we'd just be strolling
through the airport
and, you know,
people would recognize Meg,
or they'd recognize me.
And I remember we came
after like seven pages
and we were just like, high wire
acting it like we got it.
We did seven pages.
We're there.
We're finally at the stop point
and this guy goes,
"Hey, it's Meg Ryan."
And I was, like,
I was in the middle of my line.
I just said,
"That's not helpful."
[ Laughter ]
And then I was back here,
and Meg was like,
"That was amazing."
You just like...
-[ Laughing ]
-I thought it was pretty polite,
"That's not helpful."
-I mean, I do,
it's very polite.
I also want to give a break
to a traveler
at a regional airport
in Arkansas.
I don't blame them for being
a little thrown by the fact
that Duchovny and Meg Ryan
are coming down the way.
-No, I -- I --
It just wasn't helpful.
That's all I'm saying.
-Yeah, you're right.
You know what? I think it was --
-We're doing a scene.
-You gave him
a very honest fair...
-I wasn't saying
"You're an [bleep]."
I'm just saying
you're not being helpful.
[ Laughter ]
-Where do you, like -- What
is a dressing room situation
when you're shooting
in an airport?
-I was in a yoga room.
This was a fancy regional...
-The Fayetteville airport
has a yoga room?
-Had a yoga room.
-Well, now did people were is
the idea that they'll do yoga?
-I call it a yoga room.
It was a room.
-Yeah.
-It said --
[ Laughter ]
There was nothing else
in there that said yoga.
-Okay.
-[ Chuckles ]
But it was called Yoga room.
-Oh, wow.
-It was my room.
Nobody came in to do yoga
while I was there.
-Okay.
And I didn't do
any yoga in there,
but it was --
it was sweet, it was.
There was no gong.
There was no foam roller.
-But.
-Yeah, otherwise you just --
There was just
an air of yoga about it.
-It smelled more of Cinnabon.
-Okay. Yeah.
-To be honest with you.
-I mean, I think
almost every room in an airport
is kind of a Cinnabon room,
if there's any.
-I prefer that
to rank human sweat.
-Yeah. That's true.
Yeah. You know what?
-Anytime.
-Sold.
I want to ask you a question.
I know you grew up
in New York City,
Lower East Side, right?
-Yeah.
-And -- And you now...
-Yeah. Sioux Falls.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sioux Falls?
[ Chuckles ]
-I grew up in Sioux Falls.
[ Laughter ]
-How?
We're about --
You know it's
trick-or-treating tomorrow.
What were your -- What was trick
or treating like growing up
in New York City?
-Uh, fraught.
-Yeah.
Was it as bad as I
might think it was in that era?
-Yeah.
I mean, well, you know,
you wanted to find
a big building
because then you could
just get in and get out.
-Yeah.
-You could do 100 apartments.
And you'd have your your loot,
and you'd go home for the year.
But the older kids also knew
that that was going on,
and they would lay in wait
for the younger kids.
They were --
Yeah, aww.
[ Laughter ]
They were super lazy.
And they would just let us go
and get all the candy
and then like, we'll take that.
-So they just --
You got candy mugged
as a kid in New York City?
-Sure did.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
And one time, you know,
trick-or-treat,
you know, like, the --
it's trick-or-treat,
but you never think
of the treat, right?
Or you never think
of the trick.
-Yeah, you assume
the treat is implied.
You forget that you've also
asked for a trick, right?
-So I remember knocking
on this,
this door and this old lady
must have been,
like, 80 years old,
opened it.
I say she's 80,
but I was like 8,
so she might have been 35.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And then I said,
"Trick-or-treat"
And she was like,
"Trick."
And she just turned
and did a somersault.
And then she was like, "You."
I was like,
"I'll take my candy."
It's like, "No, you got to do --
You got to do the trick."
So then I did a somersault
and she gave me my candy,
and then I got mugged
for the candy.
[ Laughter ]
-You said to those bullies,
you're like,
"You owe me a somersault."
-Yeah, let's see
some somersaults.
-Do you -- have you --
Are you in your apartment now,
or do people come by your door
like, are you one of the...?
-Well, they did
when I lived in Newark.
I don't live in New York
anymore.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
In LA, no, nobody comes by.
-Nobody.
-So it's just a regular day.
-A drive by, drive by,
8-year-old behind the wheel,
"Trick-or-treat."
[ Laughter ]
Trick-or-treat.
-And you just try to throw a
Reese's through the open window?
Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-Sorry.
Sorry.
-You're going on tour
with your band?
-Yeah.
-A European tour.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-This is very exciting.
-Yeah. It is.
-Do you -- have you ever done it
before through Europe?
-Yeah, we've gone through Europe
and Eastern Europe,
and this is our second time
touring through Europe.
And you know, I've tried
to get -- no -- no offense
to your wonderful drummer
today -- but Fred.
-Yeah. You've tried to
get Fred to drum for you.
-I can't get any play
out of Fred. Fred is..
-Really because Fred
says yes to everybody.
This is shocking.
He does not -- I mean he is one
of my most talented
and least discerning friends.
-Wow.
I love Fred so much.
I did a movie with him,
and because he's one person who,
and you can corroborate
this or not,
you're not sure if he's making
fun of you all the time.
-That's true.
-Yeah.
-But he's not.
He's a lovely, sweet guy.
But you have sinking...
-He's a lovely,
authentic person.
-But you never fully trust it.
-...suspicion...
-Yeah.
-...that he's making fun of you.
And I don't know
how he does that.
-The other thing you can be
very confident with Fred
is even if you have the most
wonderful conversation with him,
he will walk away
having like the best impression
of you that he's ever had.
Like he just absorbs a person's
essence and then he can just...
-I'll have to check that out.
-Can I ask some questions?
Because these
are photos of you as --
You were a front man.
And these are very --
This is very rock and roll.
David, I'm very proud of you.
-It's so embarrassing.
-This I don't know.
This strikes me
as less rock and roll.
Because that's you.
You're on the bottom here.
-Yeah, well, you know,
if you get a good guitar,
if you're lucky enough to get
a good guitarist in your band,
you've got to treat them well.
-Yeah.
-And so I carry him around
the entire tour on my shoulders.
-I'd do it for you,
too, if you're...
-Oh, yeah.
And you have some drummers.
You have some,
you mentioned guitarists,
but there are some drummers
back there who.
-My band is so big that I have
Ben Stiller on the drums.
Yeah.
-So how did you get
Ben Stiller to drum for you?
I just asked him.
-And he -- he said yes,
and Fred said no.
[ Laughter ]
-Ben was terrific.
He came and rehearsed
a little bit.
And then we were -- It was
for the Tribeca Film Festival,
and I have my drummer.
And then at some point I said,
"Oh, my God, this is terrible.
My drummer has pulled
a hamstring.
Is there a drummer
in the house?"
And then people raise their hand
and then like,
"Oh, this guy, this guy."
And it was -- it was Ben.
-So there were
other drummers in the house.
Well, you know,
there's always --
Is there a drummer
in the house here?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There is always going to be
a drummer in the house. Yeah.
-Now, you, you shot
this film in a airport
and you are also --
You do not care for flying.
Are you still
a superstitious flier
or have you gotten over it?
-No, not so much anymore.
But when --
When I was younger,
before I was acting, I would.
I would, if I got on a flight
where there was a famous person,
-Uh-huh.
I would -- I would be...
I would think, "Oh, this plane
is not going down," because...
[ Laughter ]
...because that would be weird.
Like, it doesn't happen
all the time.
-So you feel more confident
if there's a celebrity
on your plane.
-Yeah. Tony Danza, like,
this isn't going down.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
-And then when I started
to get famous, I thought,
"Oh, people are
looking at me like,
I got to keep this thing up."
[ Laughter ]
And I was just imagining, like,
if the plane started
to have trouble
and go down,
everybody's like, "It's you.
You're not famous enough."
[ Laughter ]
"Duchovny, you bastard.
You weren't famous enough."
-You -- You
had a film at Tribeca.
Was it being a New Yorker
growing up here?
Is it special to have a movie
premiere out here?
-It was amazing.
I mean, just walking around
neighborhoods that I grew up in
and thinking,
you know, just how life
changes and grows
and just neighborhoods
that I was a kid in.
And now I'm doing these things
and it's just -- it's just
a rich feeling for me.
-Well, it's very nice.
-Not funny, but rich.
-Yeah. Not everything
has to be funny.
David, you're allowed
some richness in your life.
-I can't.
If I got to keep that plane up,
I got to be funny.
[ Laughter ]
-You still have
your undefeated record.
So let me check this.
I checked your Wikipedia.
Not one of your planes
has crashed, is that correct?
-Yeah. No.
-I'm doing well.
-Really good.
-Yeah, really well.
-It's always such
a pleasure to have you here.
Thank you so much, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Have a great tour.
David Duchovny, everybody.
"What Happens Later"
opens in theaters Friday.
We'll be right back
with Reneé Rapp.